as he's getting hugs from of course
members of Detroit Pistons as they
although his close connection
first things first Kyrie I gotta ask you
are you willing to share on your friend
Kobe Bryant okay but let's first talk
about the game okay and and and we saw
you and Spencer hug as you're coming off
it and YouTube guys dominated tonight
for your team what's it like getting
that production from Spencer
specifically off the bench it's big time
you know when you're a basketball player
and you're able to make the right plays
and play at a high intensity level and
really come out and make an impact on
the game no matter if you start coming
off the bench we've seen special guys do
that you know we're still finding what
our what our team identity looks like
and I said that's a good thing for us is
to test every single night but I'm glad
we came on and handled business it's
going and obviously it was an emotional
win we saw a free game you you you had
some clear emotions yeah what do you
want to share about Kobe Bryant who we
all know you had a very deep connection
to trying to keep my most got understand
adjust his fan hanging on his family and
his friends it's just hard to even just
conjure up the words you know you try to
find clear-cut message that you would
send to GG and Kobe and everybody that
lost their lives and such a tragedy like
that is it's hard it's hard but
I've been trying to do this the last few
days it's just trying to get ready for a
moment like this but uh I just gotta let
it be let it flow and you know I know
he's down watching as well as Gigi as
well as the young ballplayers that were
on the plane as well I was just with
them at the mambo academy working out
with them in the summertime as world of
healing girls losing their lives so it's
heartbreaking for all of us but I'm not
the only one dealing with something so I
think the most beautiful thing is that
it's connecting all of us in his seeds
that he's planted in all of us would
continue to grow and his legacy is gonna
live on forever obviously but that man
was a philosopher he was a teacher you
know he left so many great things here
for us to follow and I'm just gonna
continue to carry the torch nothing is
easy about this week and specifically
having to make those comments after this
win I think your words are going to
comfort a lot of people so thank you for
taking the time oh thank you thank you
Mark